j'ouvre notre second débat consacré aux
réponses politiques et judiciaires plus
de deux mois après les émeutes qui
avaient frappé des centaines de villes
dans 66 départements français la justice
a-t-elle été sévère comment éviter un
nouvel embrasement où en est le plan
banlieue promis par Emmanuel Macron
avant cette flambée de violence on
répondra à toutes ces questions dans un
instant mais d'abord retour à Creil dans
cette ville de l'Oise où le centre
social avait été détruit Fabien Laker et
Elliott Laura donc là c'était l'accueil
donc tout a été démonté voilà et on
pense voilà donc ils sont rentrés par
cet espace là deux mois après la
directrice du Centre Social Georges
Brassens est encore très ému
donc là on arrive dans la partie petit
enfant donc tout a vraiment été détruit
brûlé les toilettes voilà l'espace
sanitaire ça a été vraiment
on a l'impression que c'était un
défouloir de colère de haine le 29 juin
alors que la mort de Naël embrasse le
quartier du rouair des jeunes saccagent
l'accueil du centre social et mettre le
feu au bâtiment l'espace réservé à la
petite enfance ainsi qu'une cuisine on
brûlé tout est à reconstruire j'étais
prévenue faire une heure du matin par
une salariée ton un membre de sa famille
habite sur la rue John Kennedy et donc
elle m'a appelé pour me dire voilà le
centre la cuisine était en feu et que il
y avait énormément de jeunes il y avait
les habitants étaient effrayés quand le
lendemain une seconde nuit de violence
secoue la ville des habitants se
réunissent afin de défendre le centre
signe de l'attachement du quartier à ce
lieu au service des familles le maire
peine encore à trouver une explication à
cette attaque s'attaquer au Centre
Georges Brassens c'est vouloir détruire
la vie sociale de c'est comme ça que ça
a été perçu
casser la vie sociale détruire la vie
sociale dans le quartier c'est
couper rompre les liens
que les familles établissent entre elles
grâce à ce centre
c'est ici qu'on a qu'on a tous grandi
qu'on a tous vécu moi j'ai 24 ans Nabil
en a 25 et on s'a fait 24 et 25 ans
qu'on vit ici ah ouais et Nabil font
partie de ceux qui maintiennent le
dialogue avec les jeunes des quartiers
l'un est étudiant en pharmacie l'autre
travailleur social tous deux ont à cœur
de montrer une autre image de leur ville
quand on postule à des emplois etc et
qu'on dit qu'on vient de créer c'est
toujours mal vu et nous on voulait un
peu casser la stigmatisation montrant
que les jeunes ils sont engagés avec
leur association Nabil et aos encadrent
les plus jeunes organisent des sorties
culturelles et surtout du soutien
scolaire ces deux bénévoles se voient un
peu comme des grands frères on était
petit on n'a pas eu vraiment cette
chance d'avoir des grands qui nous ont
encadrés ou montrer un peu la bonne voie
et nous on essaye entre autres un peu de
montrer aux jeunes que c'est pas parce
qu'on vient de créer que l'échec est
fondamental on peut on peut réussir en
venant d'ici le besoin qui ressort le
plus au niveau de la jeunesse c'est
surtout on existe on est là ou bien ou
pas quoi
elle a organisé une marche pour appeler
au calme au lendemain de l'incendie du
centre social mais à éda bourhi Na
s’engage surtout pour l'avenir bonjour
les enfants portez uniquement par des
bénévoles son association organise
chaque soir de l'aide aux devoirs pour
les enfants prévenir le décrochage
scolaire en aidant aussi des familles le
nerf de la guerre selon Aïda une façon
en fait de soutenir aussi les parents de
dire qu'ils ne sont pas seuls
aujourd'hui pour accompagner les enfants
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui on doit être
plusieurs accompagné un enfant on a des
familles qui sont volontaires les
quartiers est quand même beaucoup de
générosité beaucoup de solidarité malgré
les deux jours de violences qui ont
secoué créé cet été haïda Nabil et Hawes
refusent de baisser les bras la
communauté d'agglomération quant à elle
devrait prochainement voter une aide
exceptionnelle à la quinzaine de
commerces qui ont vu leurs locaux
vandaliser en juin dernier
[Musique]
le département français Michel Aubouin
je commence avec vous peut-être sur ce
thème de l'ampleur l'ampleur des des
violences urbaines si ça a surpris tout
le monde ça nous a surpris est-ce que ça
vous a surpris vous aussi alors ça nous
a pas surpris en fait parce que
le phénomène des violences urbaines il
est apparu assez tôt en France
d'ailleurs il se déclenche toujours à
peu près de façon au début il avait il
se déroulait dans un quartier qui était
donné et donc il concernait d'abord les
jeunes du même quartier et puis en 2005
on l'a vu se diffuser parce que on a
compris grâce au téléphone portable qui
était entré dans les quartiers que les
quartiers c'était mieux au réseau là on
est ça se passait dans les quartiers les
plus difficiles là ça a essayé dans des
réseaux et là on a un phénomène nouveau
mais qui correspond aussi à la nouvelle
sociologie des quartiers circulaires
c'est-à-dire que les jeunes sont en
réseau plus rapide qu'avec le téléphone
portable à tout le monde a compris mais
surtout le nombre des quartiers
multiplier et beaucoup de communes qui
avaient un petit quartier avec quelques
bars HLM et qui n'avaient jamais connu
de troupes d'un seul coup ce sont
trouvés confrontés à des phénomènes
qu'elle n'avait jamais connu et on le
voit d'ailleurs c'est dur c'est comme
une là qui ont le plus souffert d'une
certaine façon parce qu'elle n'avait pas
su préparer anticiper ses crises
violentes parce que dans les quartiers
moi j'étais dans l'Essonne en 2005 donc
on avait la Grande Borne les tarteraient
les pyramides en fait tous les quartiers
que vous connaissez c'était extrêmement
violent mais là on n'a pas eu dans ces
quartiers là la même niveau de violence
que que des communes périphériques on y
reviendra notamment sur les faits des
politiques de la ville précédente dans
un rapport très intéressant qui est paru
à la fin du mois de août 25 août rapport
de l'Inspection générale de la justice
et de l'inspection générale de
l'administration c'est ces chiffres sur
la réponse judiciaire
5832 infractions
4164 procédures judiciaires 60% des
majeurs condamnés à de la prison ferme
la Fourcade ce que dit le rapport c'est
que c'est plus que la moyenne des peines
d'emprisonnement qui sont normalement
pardon prononcé par les tribunaux
correctionnels donc on peut dire quoi
que la justice a été sévère entre
guillemets après ses émeutes a été très
réactive elle a été vraiment au
rendez-vous elle a multiplié des
audiences ou des salles d'audience des
magistrats pour pouvoir les animer etc
donc on peut dire que là on a eu un
mouvement de réactivité dans un corps de
la magistrature va pas très bien quand
même la justice va pas très bien donc on
voit à quel point il y a une
mobilisation pour répondre à la demande
de justice et à la violence et à la
brutalité
que vous évoquiez mais on voit aussi que
si les peines étaient aussi sévères par
rapport aux peines prononcées
habituellement dans les tribunaux
correctionnels c'est le mode de
poursuite c'est-à-dire que c'est la
comparution immédiate qui fait cet
effet-là
d'incarcération rapide parce qu'on est
très proche de l'événement on est sur
des dossiers censés être simples dans la
culture de l'évidence à ce moment-là et
donc il y a toutes l'émotion de la
société et donc on donne beaucoup plus
facilement avec mandat de dépôt
prononcer à l'audience on va parler des
autres réponses à plus long terme et
Philippe d'allier la première réponse
aux émeutes c'était celle-là c'était
la répression la justice devait passer
parce qu'il y a eu des consignes données
par le garde des sceaux dans la société
c'était heureusement que ça s'est passé
comme ça heureusement que la réponse a
été j'allais dire à la hauteur de
l'événement parce que sinon je ne sais
pas combien de temps ça aurait durer
parce que effectivement
une différence par rapport à 2005 c'est
que les choses se sont arrêtées plus
vite peut-être différentes raisons mais
en tous les cas la réponse a été
beaucoup plus ferme
ceci étant dit heureusement que ça a été
plus court parce que les forces de
police je ne sais pas si elles auraient
pu tenir très longtemps autant qu'en
2005 avec l'intensité et effectivement
l'étalement de ces donc heureusement que
la réponse judiciaire a été a été à la
hauteur quelles leçons vous si vous
devez tirer une première leçon générale
de ce qui s'est passé c'est quoi
son élargit aux politiques de l'échec de
nos politiques publiques depuis des
années des années on va pas remonter
seulement à 2017 il y a beaucoup de
choses à dire notamment sur les
politiques de la ville mais on peut
remonter beaucoup plus loin c'est
l'affaiblissement de l'autorité de
l'État c'est une évidence absolue c'est
aussi l'échelle du système scolaire
c'est l'échec de le système
d'intégration on n'est plus en capacité
d'intégrer aujourd'hui il faut bien se
rendre compte que on accueille 300 400
000 nous arrivons par an dans ce pays ça
fait un million tous les tous les trois
ans quatre ans on est incapable de les
accueillir correctement en termes de
logement en terme d'emploi l'intégration
ça ne fonctionne plus et on a enfin moi
je suis maire d'une commune au milieu de
la Seine-Saint-Denis ce département est
en train de partir à volo en ce sens où
des communes qui ne connaissaient pas
ces phénomènes sont en train j'allais
dire de s'affaisser sociologiquement moi
je suis maire d'une commune dans
laquelle il y avait 14% de taux de
pauvreté il y a 20 ans on est à 20%
aujourd'hui et donc voilà donc il y a
une paupérisation et j'ai pas de
quartier dans la commune j'ai pas de
quartier style année 60 70 donc on est
dans autre chose avec une paupérisation
qui s'étend et puis des politiques
publiques qui sont incapables d'y faire
face on y reviendra un peu plus en
détail Michel au moins je reviens sur le
justement les communes confrontées à de
la pauvreté ou à des quartiers on va
dire prioritaires qui avaient mis en
place une politique de la ville est-ce
que c'est commune où on était plus
épargnée par les émeutes moins comment
ça s'est passé quel bilan on peut faire
là-dessus celle qui en fait toutes les
communions ont été touchées mais les
communes kurdées encore des institutions
locales c'est-à-dire dans lesquelles il
y a encore un tissu associatif ou les
élus locaux sont encore présents dans le
quartier etc sont d'une certaine façon
et donc celle qui une partie de sel en
tout cas qui sont financés par la
politique de la ville sont ont été sans
doute moins touchés sachant que par
ailleurs il faut faire il y a un autre
billet dans cette affaire c'est
l'intervention de la police donc ce que
la police est intervenue de façon
prioritaire dans les quartiers qu'elle
connaissait donc peut-être aussi que ça
ralenti les effets d'émeutes parce que
on a quand même eu beaucoup de dégâts
considérables dans des petites communes
enfin ou de des communes de 10 à 20 000
habitants y compris en province qui
avait jamais vu vos je cite souvent
Montargis par exemple si vous connaissez
c'est vraiment la porte de la province
et il y avait jamais connu
mais qu'il n'avaient jamais connu ce
type d'incident parce que là on a on a
quand même problème de réponse et de et
de force mais attendez ça j'essaie de
comprendre ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que il y a eu comme la police est
intervenue dans les dans les quartiers
qu'elle connaissait les émeutes se sont
déplacés dans d'autres
pays parce que le phénomène est apparu à
peu près partout et il est totalement
spontané enfin donc c'est il était
simplement il peut être endigué assez
vite si la réponse policière est rapide
surtout si vous avez vu mais dans ces
émeutes l'essentiel c'est des
et du pillage au magasin le pillage au
magasin ça n'avait rien à voir avec la
cause présumée des émeutes donc et en
2005 on n'est pas connu ça en 2005 on
avait pas du tout connu ça et tout à
fait donc là on a une réponse de la
police et de la justice qui est
extrêmement rapide et dans la police
avec un mode d'intervention qui est très
différent de 2005 c'est à dire avec des
unités plus mobiles y compris des unités
d'élite etc et donc c'est vite endiguer
dans les quartiers qui étaient les
quartiers les plus sensibles d'une
certaine façon Magalie la focale est-ce
qu'il faut chercher un sens politique à
ces émeutes à ceux qui sont allés je
pose la question différemment de la part
de ceux qui sont allés mettre le feu
bien sûr je pense qu'il faut chercher un
sens politique à partir du moment où on
a une population qui est très loin du
vote
on sait que donc une démobilisation
électorale de ces populations là on sait
aussi que on a une réponse sécuritaire
la justice la police qui ont très bien
travaillé
mais on voit aussi que on a un
diagnostic qui est connu depuis très
très longtemps vous l'avez évoqué
vous-même à l'instant et derrière il y a
pas eu les politiques qui auraient pu
être délivrées on a quand même eu
l'appel de Grigny on a eu le plan Borlo
qui a été salué quand même très
largement avec des consultations
intenses on connaît les diagnostics on
connaît aussi beaucoup de solutions et
derrière il n'y a pas les jeunes qui se
révoltent à ce moment-là enfin il y a
aussi des opportunistes qui vont payer
un magasin pardon d'être basique et
trivial mais c'est quand même beaucoup
ça c'est aussi une population qui est
sous-dotée en termes de d'accès à des
effectifs de santé au niveau de
l'éducation nationale sur tous les
services publics ils ont pas les mêmes
les mêmes possibilités les mêmes chances
et cumuler handicap et pourtant il y a
un foisonnement d'initiative et de et de
belles choses qui peuvent se passer
là-bas avec une discrimination quand
même assez assez lourde je suis d'accord
sur le soudage on y reviendra on parlera
du plein dans l'eau mais est-ce que
c'est pas vous pourrez répondre mais
est-ce que c'est pas un peu la culture
de l'excuse qu'on est en tendance en
train d'entendre là d'autant que la
sociologie des émeutiers a complètement
changé ils étaient très très jeunes
cette fois-ci
enfin ceux qui ont été arrêtés jugés ça
c'est le rapport de de Ligue 1 moyen
d'âge 23 ans beaucoup de célibataires
qui vivaient encore chez qui était
encore hébergé par par les parents moi
je suis toujours d'excuses je vois vous
entendre là-dessus j'ai beaucoup de mal
avec pas avec l'expression mais avec ce
qu'elle recouvre c'est-à-dire que
la République fait quand même beaucoup
pas assez dans certains quartiers c'est
une certitude mais ce manque de moyens
dans certains quartiers n'explique pas
tout et n'excuse pas tout on pourra
reparler du rôle des parents on pourra
reparler et effectivement de l'échec du
système scolaire mais il y a aussi un
lien avec les parents donc c'est pas
parce qu'on vit dans un quartier des
favorisé qu'on devient et Métiers moi
j'ai grandi dans un de ces quartiers
dans les années 60 et 70 excusez-moi
d'abord il y avait une mixité sociale
qui était bien plus importante
qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a une
concentration de la pauvreté et pour
autant personne ne s'en prenait la
voiture de son voisin personne n'allait
incendier des équipements publics etc
donc as-tu il y a une mentaliser qui a
changé et moi je ne peux plus entendre
que c'est la c'est la France qui est
coupable et responsable tout ça c'est un
échec de nos politiques publiques mais
il faut pas commencer par excant par
excuser en disant que tout peut
justifier par des difficultés sociales
non il y a aussi un problème de
l'autorité de l'état de la
reconnaissance des discussion on
pourrait parler de ce qui se passe à
l'école et les enseignants aujourd'hui
dans un département comme le mien sur la
difficulté d'enseignée être élu locale
n'en parlons pas enfin etc les
magistrats c'est également extrêmement
difficile au tribunal de Bobigny enfin
voilà je pense que la société a pris un
très mauvais virage il y a enfin ça
remonte sur les 20 30 dernières années
et on aboutit aujourd'hui à une
situation qu'on a l'impression de ne
plus maîtriser du tout votre votre
réponse puisque finalement on voit deux
deux perceptions qui sont quand même
assez assez différents
stigmatisée on parle de quoi on parle de
de pognon de dingue on parle
d'assistanat on parle de personnes qui
seraient mal éduquées on parle mais on
oublie toujours de mentionner qui a
énormément de choses qui s'y passent qui
sont très très positives et que le pacte
républicain c'est pas seulement des
devoirs pour les populations c'est aussi
ne pas être stigmatisé ne pas être
discriminé ne pas être contrôlé de
manière abusif et discriminatoire il y a
aussi tout ça donc la rupture de la
citoyenneté elle est aussi là elle est
c'est pas du tout l'excuse non mais je
suis je suis d'accord avec vous les
choses sont complexes les choses sont
complexes et les responsabilités sont
partagées mais globalement on a trop
entretenu et certains d'ailleurs dans le
discours politique aujourd'hui enfin on
pourra leur aller de la gauche l'extrait
de la gauche de la gauche ou l'extrême
gauche du discours de Mélenchon et de
ses troupes sur la police de la haine
qui se développe franchement certains
ont aussi une responsabilité certains
sont dans la détestation de la France
pour des raisons que j'ai parfois du mal
à comprendre donc si vous voulez les
responsabilités sont très partagées et
c'est un échec globalement de nos
politiques publiques et je serai remis à
dire qu'en Seine-Saint-Denis
effectivement les moyens de l'État ne
sont pas à la hauteur des problématiques
que nous rencontrons sur le terrain on
va parler des réponses poétiques
notamment au gouvernement mais quand
même je veux bien vous donner la parole
et je sais pas si vous souhaitez
arbitrer cette c'est cette différence de
perception en fait comme je suis quand
même encore beaucoup dans les quartiers
je je vois pas les choses se fait de la
même façon c'est à dire quand il faut
pas oublier quand même que l'essentiel
des victimes de ses émeutes c'est
justement les gens des quartiers on
était à tout à l'heure le centre social
ce qui pardon mais ceux qui mettent le
feu à 100% leurs parents et d'ailleurs
c'est pas c'est pas sans danger parce
que je pense que si on a un nouvel
épisode de ce type c'est les gens des
quartiers qui défendront leur voiture
leur appartement etc et ça ça sera
beaucoup plus grave que ce qu'on a connu
là donc je pense qu'il faut faire très
attention on a une population juvénile
en France qui est absolument
incontrôlable on a maintenant à peu près
2000 on a 2500 quartiers politiques de
la ville et puis il faut rajouter 500
autres qu'on a découvert cette occasion
on est à peu près 2000 quartiers dans
lequel vous avez un petit noyau d'une
centaine de jeunes qui sont devenus
incontrôlables sans multiplier par 2000
ça fait 200000 200000 donc le la
capacité de mobilisation de 200000
personnes très mobiles tous connectés
etc elle est considérable ça le bon et
ces jeunes là comment ils se sont
déconnectés de la Société des
scolarisations précoces difficultés
parentales ce qu'il faut voir je veux
dire quand vous rencontrez les enfants
de 10
[Musique]
l'éducation va mieux quand l'intégration
a réussi quand le logement est efficace
parce qu'on sait tous qu'il y a des
liens entre tout ça et d'autres encore
alors je crois que il y aurait moins de
travail pour nos policiers et éducation
intégration logement Laetitia en attend
un plan banlieue promis par Emmanuel
Macron depuis longtemps avant même c'est
urbaines mais pour l'instant on le voit
pas venir c'était une promesse de
campagne du candidat Macron juste avant
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 il parle de ce
plan qui s'appelle Thomas Cartier 2030
donc on connaît déjà son titre on
l'attendait pourquoi on n'a pas eu ce
plan tout simplement parce que Manuel
Macron l'a lancé quand il s'est déplacé
à Marseille vous vous souvenez fin juin
il en a même dévoilé quelques grandes
mesures par exemple accueille entre 8h
et 18h des jeunes dans tout les
quartiers avec des activités culturelles
sportives une aide aux devoirs dans les
quartiers prioritaires prioritaires de
la ville évidemment une scolarisation
des deux ans une embauche un peu plus
axée sur justement toutes ces
populations avec l'engagement de 5000
entreprises c'était l'objectif
d'Emmanuel Macron donc il y en avait des
mesures vous voyez il avait commencé un
peu à les égrainer et puis la mort du
jeune Naël et les émeutes qui ont suivi
ont stoppé et on réduit l'exécutif au
silence et pourtant la première ministre
ils avaient de borne avait réuni un
comité interministériel de la ville on
s'en souvient c'est le 30 juin oui et
elle l'a fait aucune alors qu'elle avait
prévu de le faire pourquoi parce que
encore une fois avec les émeutes de
contexte voilà fait que elle ne pouvait
finalement rien dire du côté d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis
est-ce qu'on peut dire silence radio
pour l'instant oui et pourtant il y a
beaucoup de pourtant dans cette édition
pourtant début juillet le président
avait reçu plus de 300 mètres il a reçu
le plus de 300 m vous étiez alors pour
pour résumer à gauche on lui demandait
plus de moyens à droite en lui demandait
de plus de sécurité caddie le président
Emmanuel Macron a finalement annoncé un
plan d'urgence pour la reconstruction
des quartiers sinistrés donc à ce moment
là dans la foulée immédiate des émeutes
le mot d'ordre de la majorité et on l'a
dit ici c'était de rétablir l'ordre
républicain d'ailleurs c'est Bruno Le
Maire qui l'avait dit dans une interview
on ne rétablit pas l'ordre de la Nation
avec le désordre des comptes publics on
a compris l'esprit du moment
sous-entendu on va pas ouvrir les vannes
et les laisser beaucoup d'argent
avec régime de sanctions pénales on l'a
dit mais aussi financière pour les
familles des émeutiers est-ce que ce
plan pardon le quartier 2030 et enterré
au fond d'un tiroir on en est où et bien
écoutez on le pensait et puis non
finalement on apprend qu'il y a une
circulaire qui est datée du 31 août donc
vraiment c'est tout récent on l'apprend
quand la semaine dernière et cette
circulaire donne quand même assoupli
l'agenda qu'il existe un agenda pour ce
plan quartier 2030 alors ce plan
s'appelle maintenant engagement quartier
2030 unité bon il y a une grande
concertation citoyenne qui est pilotée
par le président de assez le feu c'est
une association qui est très présente
dans les quartiers notamment pendant les
émeut de 2005 et cette grande
concertation ira jusqu'à la fin du mois
d'octobre
au printemps elle ira jusqu'à la fin du
mois d'octobre à la fin de l'année 2023
il y aura une nouvelle géographie des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville et
puis il y aura aussi les contrats
d'huile pour la période 2024 2030 qui
seront signés avant le 31 mars 2024 mais
pas de communication publique pour
l'instant c'est ça pour l'instant une
circulaire mais quand on insiste un peu
quand même du côté de Matignon on nous
laisse entendre qu'Elisabeth borne
devrait réunir à nouveau comité
intermédiaire de la ville le 9 octobre
c'est pour bientôt et peut-être qu'à
cette occasion elle pourra présenter ce
fameux plan quartier 2030 à moins
qu'elle n'en fasse que l'introduction
pour que Emmanuel Macron voilà donc qui
porte ce plan depuis 2022 on le rappelle
l'incarne et le présente enfin Maggie
focale est-ce que pour vous il y a un
manque d'ambition politique très clair
d'Emmanuel Macron alors là quand même je
pense que c'est assez net puisque donc
cette réunion sur la ville qui a eu lieu
en juin aurait dû se tenir déjà bien
avant avait été reporté donc elle s'est
retrouvée au milieu d'une actualité
extrêmement brûlante qui montrait déjà
qu'il y avait un atermoiement qui est
inexplicable contenu de la situation qui
est explosive et que la réponse
sécuritaire ne peut pas suffire pour
pouvoir calmer le jeu il faut pas gérer
ce sujet à la petite semaine il faut
vraiment avoir un pack un pain un
paradigme dans le plan il n'y a pas que
de la réponse sécuritaire vous l'avez
entendu la mesure concrète tout à fait
mais les quand on voit l'ambition qui
avait dans le rapport Borlo de 2018 les
propositions qui sont sur la table
depuis des années on voit quand même
qu'on est très très loin de quelque
chose qui a de l'ampleur et qui en tout
cas peut se décliner sur tous les plans
pour pouvoir aborder cette thématique
complexe est-ce que c'est seulement une
question d'argent bien sûr que non c'est
aussi une question de représentation moi
j'ai entendu quand même beaucoup de
clichés sur la drogue qui serait le
premier employeur c'est faux dans les
quartiers sur le fait que ce serait que
du communautarisme quand on regarde les
données scientifiques des sociologues de
trajectoire et horizons et origines
pardon de le numéro 2 parce que donc
c'est une étude qui a été relancée on
voit qu'en fait les couples deviennent
de plus en plus mixtes et que donc les
petits enfants de la troisième
génération d'immigrés sont dans la dans
quelque chose qui est très loin de de
d'union qui ne serait pas mixe donc on
voit à quel point la population se
mélange on voit aussi que c'est des le
niveau d'ascension par le diplôme un
progresse dans les pour les populations
de migrées de génération en génération
donc il y a des tas de choses qui sont
comme ça valorisables donc vous ne
faites pas le lien entre la question de
la politique migratoire et les violences
urbaines que faisaient Monsieur le Maire
tout à l'heure moi je crois qu'il faut
prendre ça avec beaucoup beaucoup de
prudence il faut regarder les travaux
des sociologues et aussi des économistes
parce que on a quand même mystère Duflot
qui a produit beaucoup de choses sur
l'accompagnement pour sortir de la
pauvreté et ça pourrait vraiment
inspirer les politiques pour voir qu'en
fait on peut arriver
on peut pas accueillir toute la misère
du monde
il faut en prendre ça on était en 89
la misère du monde c'est des gens qui
sont là qui sont pour beaucoup français
et qu'on accompagne pour qu'ils
deviennent aussi des gens qui sont des
forces vives de la nation et qui vont
produire de l'argent
je ne fais pas un lien direct entre
l'immigration tout à l'heure dans la
dans la liste des mots c'est
par parler de l'échec scolaire et ça ça
concerne aussi bien des Français de une
deux trois quatre cinq générations
d'accord surtout dans un appartement
comme le mien de l'affaiblissement de
l'autorité de l'État et effectivement
d'une immigration qui est incontrôlée
dans tous ces quartiers et quel que soit
c'est particulièrement vrai en
Seine-Saint-Denis mais dans tous ces
quartiers quand vous sortez une famille
des difficultés et que vous en récupérez
deux autres tandises au moins aussi
importante si ce n'est plus grande
est-ce que vous pensez qu'à moyen
équivalent depuis des années on va y
arriver non on n'y arrive pas et donc
vous avez des quartiers qui finissent et
même des villes ou même des départements
qui finissent par se spécialiser dans
l'accueil des gens les plus en
difficulté plus pauvre
donc si vous voulez comment voulez-vous
que ce département s'en sorte en plus
avec des moyens de l'État qui sont
insuffisants si on continue à concentrer
les populations les plus pauvres et les
primo arrivants ça n'est pas possible
mais est-ce qu'on a essayé autre chose
que ça cette espèce de concentration de
la pauvreté ou de la misère
on pourrait essayer d'autres choses
d'abord on a une situation qui est
propre à la France qui sont ces
quartiers qui datent d'une époque
ancienne parce que tout ça décret de
1969 donc la création des ZUP à partir
des années 70 etc qu'on aurait dû
démolir depuis longtemps parce qu'en
fait ils étaient tous destinés on a
conservé à cause du roman familial dans
les années 76 donc on a une situation
qui n'existe qu'en France de ces
logements collectifs très resserrés dans
des quartiers fermés sur eux-mêmes et
souvent éloignés des centres-villes ça
c'est la question des quartiers ça
concerne pas les émeutes n'ont pas
concerné que ces quartiers là le cœur ça
fait 1500 quartiers en gros 10 à 15000
habitants par quartier est quand même
plusieurs presque de millions
d'habitants qui vivent dedans voilà ça
c'est le c'est un des sujets alors
qu'est-ce qu'on ne fait pas en France
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire moi j'ai
été directeur de l'intégration des
étrangers pendant 4 heures de 2009 à
2013 en 4 ans j'ai vu mes crédits
diminuent un tiers et donc c'est aussi
une question d'argent et c'est aussi une
question d'accueil un moment si vous
accueillez des des populations enfin des
familles nouvelles et que vous leur
dites pas voilà ce qu'on va faire pour
vous apprenez le français comment vous
vos enfants vont aller à l'école etc
comment voulez-vous que ça se passe tout
seul quoi enfin pendant le désir mais ça
marche pas et ça marche dans plein
d'autres pays mais ça marche pas en
France parce qu'on n'aimait pas les
moyens alors nous on a concentré nos
moyens financiers il faut bien dire sur
le bâti une vision qui est quand même ça
qui a été faux depuis le temps qu'on
fait la politique de la ville les
milliards d'euros qu'on a je l'ai dit
devant la Cour des comptes qui en a
convenu les milliards d'euros les
dizaines de milliards d'euros qu'on a
mis dans la rénovation la reconstruction
etc ça produit des faits considérables
on devait les détruire donc on a fini
par détruire trop tard
on en a détruit beaucoup mais mais
l'ampleur des moyens affectés c'est ces
opérations urbaines comparé aux
résultats il y a une disproportion on
aurait mis plus de moyens dont par
exemple l'accompagnement scolaire moi je
suis quand même assez Farid de voir tous
ces enfants qui viennent qui parlent pas
français je parle pas des émeutes
forcément c'est notre sujet mais qui
parle pas français qui sont mal pris en
charge parce qu'il y a pas les moyens
nécessaires parce qu'on les a pas mis en
place et qui au bout d'un certain temps
finissent par se déscolariser sans qu'on
trouve de solutions pour
l'aéroscoloriser voilà tout ça c'est
c'est tout ce tissu là qui est qui est
en train de de disparaître alors je vais
vous redonner la parole on va faire le
tour grâce à Audrey betas des des
propositions des idées qui sont voilà
sortis des tiroir plupart des
différentes formations politiques
rebonsoir Audrey voilà et dites nous un
peu quelle proposition pu être faire par
les différents camps politiques après
les émeutes les violences urbaines et
bien c'est un peu un concours Lépine des
propositions à voir celle qui vont aller
jusqu'au bout la droite mises
essentiellement sur le régalien l'ordre
et la réponse pénale pour lutter contre
ce qu'elle appelle le délitement de
l'autorité dans les quartiers alors
juste après les violences qui ont suivi
la mort du jeune Naël erikiotti le chef
des républicains a proposé le doublement
du nombre de centres éducatifs fermés et
l'augmentation du nombre de places en
prison plus 80 000 d'ici 2027 c'est 5000
de plus que ce qui est prévu une
politique pénale plus ferme c'est aussi
l'idée du rassemblement national qui
évoque même tenez vous bien des centres
de regrettement
on entend parler aujourd'hui d'appel à
l'apaisement de rhétorique d'apaisement
il faut maintenant que ce soit suivi de
fait le rétablissement de l'ordre public
la reine des migrations et le retour à
une politique pénale soit beaucoup plus
ferme beaucoup plus efficace notamment à
la mineur qui doivent être placés pour
les plus récalcitrants d'entre eux dans
des centres éducatifs fermés voire dans
des centres de redressement qui
pourraient être encadrés parlant autre
proposition dans la foulée des violences
souvenez-vous les républicains et le RN
plaidé pour la mise en place de
sanctions financières pour les parents
de mineurs délinquants Bruno Retailleau
le chef des républicains au Sénat en
avait parlé en juillet il venait de
rencontrer la première ministre
établir la possibilité de primer de
priver ces familles par exemple de
prestations sociales et d'allocations
familiales mais il faut souligner que
c'est un serpent de mer politique pour
l'instant aucun texte n'a été déposé au
Sénat dans ce sens j'ai tout de même
trouvé à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi du rassemblement
national qui a été déposée à la fin de
l'été et qui doit être maintenant étudié
par la commission des affaires sociales
Thomas pour la droite et la droite
radicale à gauche pas de texte non plus
la gauche dans son entendre dans son
ensemble appelle cependant à repenser en
profondeur les choses en misant sur le
long terme en commençant par la
politique de la ville en réalité
qu'importe la couleur politique beaucoup
mentionne le plan Borlo vous en avez
parlé ce plan d'ensemble qui a été
présenté en 2018 et balayé en grande
partie par Emmanuel Macron on s'en
souvient et bien il revient au cœur des
propositions je vais vous faire écouter
une interpellation adressée à la
première ministre c'était lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
avant l'été
c'est la grande coalition proposée par
Jean-Louis Borloo chevet des piliers
fondamentaux que sont la justice l'ordre
public la jeunesse la santé l'habitat
l'énergie la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique vous avez dit hier madame la
Première ministre est à l'écoute des
propositions et bien elles sont faites
comment comptez-vous maintenant
effectivement les mettre en oeuvre et si
ce plan fait l'unanimité c'est parce
qu'il a été réalisé en concertation avec
les acteurs de terrain et les élus
locaux peu importe leur étiquette
politique Thomas merci beaucoup Audrey
buttaz donc on parlait du plan borloge
un document qui date de du moment où
l'ancien ministre de la Ville qui avait
été chargé d'une mission par Emmanuel
Macron on est en 2018 il vient de
remettre son rapport il est persuadé que
le Président de la République va
l'appliquer
notre système n'est pas attentif nous ne
sommes pas vers l'égalité républicaine
il y a beaucoup moins de moyens dans ces
quartiers qu'ailleurs il faut d'abord
tordre le cou à la légende que j'entends
pour ça que j'ai fait un travail précis
que vous avez vu on a mis de l'argent ça
sert un lien
il y a beaucoup moins de moyens premier
travail c'était de regarder ça puis
ensuite comment refait une société
ensemble comment on fait ensemble pour
vivre ensemble il faut faire ensemble
c'est un plan extrêmement précis qui est
proposé au Président lui qu'on a décidé
bien entendu mais de toute façon ça se
fera de toute façon évidemment
désillusion pour pour Jean-Louis Borlo
Magali la Fourcade
c'est une occasion manquée on peut c'est
le minimum que l'on puisse dire
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait dans ce plan
Borlo qui aurait pu éventuellement
changer la donne alors il y avait déjà
beaucoup de mesures concrètes il y avait
comme vous l'avez dit
un consensus puisque il y avait eu
énormément de d'audition de gens de
terrain de tout bord politique donc on
était au-delà de l'idéologie on était
dans quelque chose de aller maintenant
on y va on a un projet collectif pour
faire société comme il a dit donc de
trouver comment on intègre dans la
communauté nationale les principes et
qu'on les décline au niveau local et
puis je pense qu'il y avait aussi
l'émergence d'une méthode qui est qui
est celle qui est quand même recommandée
par les Nations Unies parce qu'il faut
aussi vous disiez et j'étais à
l'étranger mais il faut aussi regarder
les recommandations qui viennent de des
organes qui nous qui nous supervisent au
niveau des droits humains et il y a
l'approche fondée sur les droits de
l'homme qui vise à ce qu'on associe
toujours les populations concernées ce
qu'on appelle les bénéficiaires aux
populations aux politiques publiques il
est concerne qu'on les consulte avant de
de décider
en termes d'éducation en termes de
sécurité aussi vous l'avez dit les
pendant les émeutes les habitants de ces
quartiers ont été victimes de violences
et de et de dégradation donc il faut les
consulter les associer puis derrière il
faut toujours évaluer en toute
transparence les politiques publiques
qui sont conduites pour pouvoir après
ajuster et être efficace là maintenant
le sujet tellement grave bon je pense
qu'on est bien d'accord sur ce
diagnostic là il faut une vision il faut
une méthode et puis il faut décliner ce
qui a déjà été recommandé mille fois
Philippe d'allier est-ce que vous
espérez encore un plan de d'ampleur une
ambition voilà à la hauteur de ce qui se
de des enjeux je veux en Corée
d'ailleurs c'est un très grand gâchis
parce que les choses avaient pas si mal
commencé quand Emmanuel Macron a été élu
en 2017 rappelez-vous du dédoublement
des classes dans les quartiers
d'éducation prioritaire les classes de
CP ouais mais ça c'était une excellente
mesure si effectivement on avait
continué en montant jusqu'au CM2 et
regarder ce qu'on fait au collège et ça
c'est une bonne mesure de départ il y a
eu le plan Borlo je vais travailler avec
du Jean-Louis Borloz ici au Sénat il
était venu me voir avec ses équipes
pendant une heure et demie on avait
parlé finance des collectivités locales
de la péréquation financière donc on
avait mis beaucoup d'espoir dans
effectivement le travail qu'il allait
rendre et puis souvenez-vous Macron a
tout balayé en disant que de mal blanc
elle est pas réglé le problème comme ça
et puis après plus rien
c'est ça qui est incroyable alors est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il est possible de
rattraper le retard mais écoutez je vais
encore espérer que oui mais il faut bien
prendre conscience que moi je veux
revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur
l'enrue il y a pas un maire qui a
bénéficié des projets en rue qui vous
dirait aujourd'hui qu'il fallait pas le
faire donc
nationale rénovation il fallait le faire
traiter le bâti et les quartiers mais il
fallait en parallèle effectivement le
volet éducatif il fallait mettre le
paquet en même temps que la sécurité
mais l'emploi également mais si vous
n'avez pas de formation et s'il y a pas
de réussite scolaire on sait que
l'employé ailleurs c'est très difficile
et donc voilà il manque de il manque la
deuxième jambe de la politique de la
ville celle-là n'est pas là et Macron
s'est arrêté en route pour le plan
quartier 2030 je suis sûr qu'il y aura
80% des mesures du plan Bordeaux
ce qui sait ce qui serait un aveu de de
d'erreur on va dire de la part du du
président de la République Michel
Aubouin
vous vous qui êtes voilà qui baignait
dans ces questions depuis des années à
dire des décennies est-ce que vous êtes
allés de déception en déception
non mais je meurs toujours la même
difficulté c'est à dire que
chez nos décideurs politiques une forme
d'incompréhension du sujet alors les
élus qui sont au contact comprennent
bien de quoi il s'agit mais dès qu'on
passe une certaine seuil à ce moment-là
et là on l'a vu enfin je pense que le
président comprend pas du tout quel est
le sujet je
le dis comme ça parce que je le vois ça
de loin je le connais pas mais mais
quand même on est quand même étonné qui
est pas qui est pas une prise en compte
moi je veux dire modestement personne me
consulte alors que j'ai rendu des
rapports sur le sujet des rapports qui
certains sont des tiroirs
[Musique]
c'est quand même assez étonnant qu'on
n'est pas une réflexion un peu large
au-delà du des cercles habituels la
politique de la ville et ses
associations ses professionnels etc pour
essayer de repenser cette question qui
est compliquée est-ce qu'il y a pas
aussi une question de alors j'allais
dire cynisme mais bon en tout cas de
Houdou de crainte des conséquences
politiques d'un d'un plan Beaulieu je
dis ça parce que écoutons le président
du Rassemblement national la droite
radicale qui refuse l'idée même d'un
plan banlieue ce serait un cadeau fait
osemetiers voilà ce qui nous dit Jordan
Bardella
je pense qu'un nouveau plan banlieue
dans ces conditions seraient un cadeau
fait aux émeutiers absolument inouï et
un signal de laxisme désastreux à
l'encontre de gens qui ont défi
l'autorité de l'État et qui se considère
impuni par la justice de notre pays je
veux bien sont les dernières minutes de
notre débat vous entendre les uns et les
autres là-dessus Michel au bon est-ce
que c'est pas aussi pour ça que Emmanuel
Macron a mis son plan de banlieue sous
le sous la pile ça serait quand même
très étonnant mais alors je peut-être
mais ça veut dire aussi que la
sociologie de nos départements et pas
connu comme est-ce que on parlait par
exemple la Seine-Saint-Denis c'est
intéressant parce que vous savez comme
le logement social est totalement saturé
il faut quand même plus de 10 ans de
région parisienne pour obtenir un
logement et le taux de rotation est
inférieur à 5%, ça veut dire que tous
les gens qui arrivent dont on parlait
tout à l'heure eux ils sont pas en
logements HLM ils sont dans l'habitat
diffus dans des pavillons qui sont sous
loués par par quartier et donc ça c'est
la nouvelle réalité la nouvelle
sociologie de au département donc si
déjà on prend pas en compte celle des
quartiers et qu'on voit pas arriver
celle là mais dans 10 ans on sera où
je veux revenir sur ce que dit Jordan
Bardella il veut faire croire que la
politique de Émile ça consiste à
distribuer des subventions à des
associations qui en France qu'elles
veulent c'est ça en fait ce qu'il y a
derrière son discours mais c'est qui qui
ne connaît pas grand chose à la
politique de la ville en tous les cas où
concret voilà quand je parle de réussite
éducative de réussite scolaire quand je
parle d'Accompagnement des Parents
l'aide à la parentalité etc c'est un tas
de dispositif qu'il faut effectivement
renforcer mais c'est aussi des moyens
supplémentaires pour la justice pour la
police dans un département comme le mien
mais ce qui a fait tout ceci des
français et notamment celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent qui ah oui bon donc tant
qu'il a fallu casser pour obtenir un
plan banlieue parce que ce discours là
on l'entend on l'a entendu après les
gilets jaunes par exemple moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'essayer de trouver
des solutions parce que la situation est
grave c'est bien plus grave ce qui s'est
passé
au mois de juin dernier que ce qui
s'était passé en 2005 qu'est-ce qu'on
attend qu'est-ce qu'on attend les forces
de l'or ne soient plus capables de
contrôler ce type d'émeutes qui
pourraient bien arriver si jamais ça
prenait encore de l'ampleur qui peut
souhaiter cela qui veut la politique du
pire donc regardons les choses en face
et prenons les bonnes décisions Magali
la Fourcade peut-être pas là-dessus sur
mes il y a un message peut-être que
parce que en préparant l'émission j'ai
vu que vous étiez avec la Commission
nationale consistative des droits de
l'homme en pointe là-dessus sur le les
droits non réclamés c'est ça qu'est-ce
que c'est ça parce que là aussi on est
dans une idée reçue qu'il faut peut-être
un peu balayer voilà d'accord quand on
parle des émeutiers et d'un cadeau aux
émeutiers des émotics sont traités d'un
point de vue judiciaire beaucoup sont
partis en prison voilà ça c'est traité
il faut traiter le la complexité des
problèmes là où ils sont et on connaît
un certain nombre de mesures qu'il faut
mettre en place donc maintenant faire un
plan un plan 2030 banlieue et c'est
absolument nécessaire et il faut le
faire de manière urgente pour éviter une
autre explosion parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire après on va encore faire
plus de répression donc là un des sujets
de la République elle doit s'appliquer
partout et quand on est titulaire de
droit même si on est d'origine immigrée
à partir du moment où on est titulaire
de droit on est français où on est en
situation complètement régulière on a le
droit à pouvoir toucher un certain
nombre de prestations sociales d'accéder
à certains membres de services publics
etc or dans ces quartiers les services
publics sont en recul par rapport au
reste du territoire alors que ce sont
ces quartiers qui en ont beaucoup qui ne
touchent pas les droits en question
contre l'idée de l'assistanat ces
immigrés qui piquent nos allocs quand on
regarde d'un point de vue économique et
sociologique les choses on s'aperçoit
qu'un taux de non recours dans ces
quartiers qui est énorme alors on peut
se dire chouette on fait des économies
mais en fait c'est une dette sociale
vis-à-vis de ces populations qui eux
sont les plus vulnérables et à partir du
moment où on regarde les travaux des
économistes on s'aperçoit que si on leur
donnait ce à quoi ils ont droit qui est
un du et bien il pourrait devenir des
forces d'autant plus vivre pour la
nation enrichir notre PIB s'il faut
penser qu'en termes de ruissellement
économique moi je pense en termes
d'humain bien sûr mais donc il y aurait
résultats de de choses à en tirer si au
lieu de mettre l'accent sur la photo de
prestation sociale ou les ou
l'assistanat ont montré qu'il y a
d'autres fraudes beaucoup plus corrisifs
pour l'État comme les fraudes fiscales
et qui sont qui nuisent au pacte social
et donc il faut lutter contre le nombre
court allez tout le monde a pu faire
passer ces idées ces messages c'était
passionnant il y a eu pas mal d'idées
reçues balayées dans des bas merci à
tous d'y avoir participé je vous dis à
bientôt sur Public Sénat merci à toutes
et à tous de votre fidélité on se
retrouve évidemment
lundi noter que demain matin Oriane
mansini reçoit l'historien à Benjamin
Stora dans la matinale de public sénage
vous souhaite une belle soirée à toutes
et à tous